un choc effroyable de la tôle déchiqueté
voilà ce qu'il reste après un choc
frontal d'une rare violence
une voiture qui roulait à contresens a
percuté de plein fouet une camionnette
selon les premiers éléments les
responsables de l'accident seraient des
jeunes venus de lyon pour s'amuser en
roulant à contresens portes ouvertes et
en faisant demi tour sur l'autoroute
les gendarmes n'ont pas réussi à les
intercepter l'un des passagers est mort
le conducteur est grièvement blessé
la deuxième personne décédée
l'automobiliste qui arrivait en face il
faut d'ailleurs préciser que un véhicule
avait été signalé comme en provenance du
sud en provenance du rhône est
effectivement avec des manoeuvres
extrêmement dangereuse sur l'autoroute
les gendarmes avaient été déjà informé
chercher à neutraliser ce véhicule est
malheureusement ils sont intervenus trop
tard
les secours ont été amenés à procéder à
deux désincarcérations une sur chaque
véhicule donc deux intègrent des
incarcérations assez lourde puisque les
deux personnes étaient relativement
coincé
elle met en oeuvre tous nos moyens pour
pouvoir justement mais dégager fait
sapeurs pompiers ont été mobilisés ainsi
que deux équipes du smur de mâcon
les gendarmes du peloton motorisé de
charnay les mâcon ont procédé aux
premières constatations
des prélèvements sanguins ont été
effectués afin de déterminer si les
conducteurs étaient alcoolisés ou drogué
l'autoroute a6 a été coupée dans le sens
lyon-paris ce qui a entraîné un bouchon
de 2 km une voie de circulation a été
rouverte vers 2 heures du matin le
trafic est redevenu normal aux alentours
de 4 heures